Apple's upcoming March event is going to
be bigger than you think jam-packed with
multiple new products across different
categories including a revolution in
Apple's iPad lineup but what I want to
focus on in this video is the Mac
because Apple's going to be doing
something they've never done before and
thankfully we're starting to get more
and more leaks and rumors that are
beginning to confirm that this event
will be happening in March so with that
said let's get into all of the puzzle
pieces surrounding this upcoming event
and how it all comes together first of
all you need to realize that March
events are more common than you think
with apple hosting spring events six out
of the last N9 years with five of them
being in March and it makes sense
financially because that's around the
time people start getting their tax
refunds so there is more money flowing
around to buy Tech products but getting
into the actual leaks that confirm the
date of this event we just got a crazy
rumor last week from instant digital on
waybo and it actually makes a ton of
sense apparently apple is planning a
huge refresh of all of their Mac
peripherals like the magic keyboard the
Magic Mouse and the magic Trackpad
moving them all over to USBC just like
they've done with the new iPhone 15
lineup as well as the airpods and this
will apparently be happening in the
spring of
2024 so finally after a decade or longer
with lightning apple is finally pushing
forward with the switch that everyone
has been asking for but the really weird
thing here is that we were actually all
expecting these new USBC peripherals to
come with the M3 iMac but no we
literally just got the same iMac in the
same color options and with the same
lightning accessories nothing at all
changed other than the chip being
upgraded to the M3 and they didn't even
make new marketing material for it they
literally just changed the wallpapers
within the same animated videos and
called it good which is honestly so
disappointing so why in the world would
Apple not release these USBC peripherals
alongside the iMac and choose to wait
until the spring well I believe apple
has a master plan to change their Mac
lineup forever in a massive way which
changes so big that it Justified waiting
for the spring to make it a bigger deal
alongside a game-changing new Mac
product but before I get into the that
I've got to show you guys a couple of
awesome new products from our sponsor
vessie this right here is my current
favorite sneaker for the winter season
the storm burst high top sneaker in
space black which is waterproof all the
way up to the top with vess's unique
diamondx knit material while also being
super comfy to walk around all day in
like I did on our recent New York City
trip they've also got their new stylish
Ulta High toop sneaker with a nice touch
of of vegan leather and Diamond Tex with
excellent grip on the bottom and it
comes in three colors black white and
dune beige my wife's personal favorite
pair of vessis is the weekend Chelsea
that's also great for winter and if you
don't get any snow where you're at
they've also got a bunch of other
options like their overcast jacket and
Soho sneakers all waterproof and you can
order any of them today by using the
link below to get 15% off your first
order now getting back to that new
game-changing Mac product that's of
course a fully redesigned M3 Mac Mini
yes this Mac Mini was conveniently left
out of the October event for some odd
reason even though it'll come packing
the same M3 and M3 Pro chip options that
Apple has already revealed back in
October and the crazier thing is that
back in August Mark Gman literally
confirmed that Apple started testing a
new Mac with a model identifier Mac
1512 coming with an M3 chip with an 8
core CPU 10 core GPU and 24 gigs of RAM
which perfectly matches the core layout
that we're expecting to come to the Mac
Mini and we definitely know that that
unreleased Mac is not the M3 MacBook Air
which I'm going to talk about in just a
minute because the 13 and 15in M3
MacBook airs have already been confirmed
to come with code names of Mac 151 and
152 which is way different than the new
1512 code name and since there are no
other Mac products that we're expecting
with the M3 chip I can say with 100%
certainty that this new leaked Mac in
testing will for sure be the M3 Mac Mini
so the big question is this why did
Apple leave it out of the October event
and when is it coming well it makes
sense to leave it out because the iMac
and Mac Mini are in the same product
category consumer desktop Max so it
makes sense to only reveal one of them
at a time so I fully believe that the
only date Apple can release it is at the
March event because I don't think Apple
can wait much longer because the next
possible Mac event will only take place
in June and that might already be too
late to release another product with the
same chips that we would already have
for many months and in my opinion it
would be perfect to release the Mac Mini
alongside the M3 MacBook Air models
which are already expected in March
according to Mark German's latest report
which that event would also include the
new M3 iPad Pro and iPad Air which by
the way the display panel shipments are
already going full steam ahead for the
March event and also Apple loves
releasing clusters of different products
that share the same chips just like they
did in October and finally I believe
that Apple will absolutely take
advantage of the June WWDC event to
reveal the new M3 Ultra chip which is
perfect for that event since we know
it's not coming as soon as the spring
event because there are too many other
products releasing at that time and I
don't think Apple will wait until the
fall since that'll be too long being a
full year between the M3 Max and the M3
Ultra reveal so that is why we should
100% expect both the M3 MacBook Airline
and the M3 Mac Mini to come at this
upcoming March event but it doesn't stop
there because I believe Apple has the
perfect opportunity to completely
redesign the Mac Mini which they haven't
done in many years and I don't know if
you remember this or not but a couple of
years ago Ian Zelo worked with John prer
on some new redesigned Mac Mini renders
that looked completely legit and like
something Apple would make going back to
their retro styling but making the Mac
Mini so much thinner and better looking
the only downside to this theory is that
almost a year ago in January M quo made
a prediction that the new Mac Mini in
2024 will likely reuse the same form
factor design but who knows maybe things
have changed over the past year now on
top of that we already know for sure
that the 13 and 15-in MacBook airs are
coming at the March event which were
also left out of the October event and
it makes sense why because Apple wanted
to sell the new, 1600 $ M3 MacBook Pro
with the same chip so it gets the
spotlight and also because Apple only
recently released the first M2 version
of the 15-in MacBook Air in the summer
so they need to wait a little bit longer
to update it which would make sense in
March and other than that we're of
course expecting the new M3 iPad Pro
with a crazy redesign which will
revolutionize the iPad lineup with the
best dual panel Ola display ever made
alongside a brand new redesigned
aluminum magic keyboard 2 and a more
subtle update to the iPad Air so with
that said if you're as excited as I am
for the March event subscribe above for
more updates like this and definitely
check out one of those two videos right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next
[Music]
one